hey good afternoon everybody it's uh
coming up on one o'clock uh
central time i'll get started here just
going through a couple last minute uh
technical checks make sure sound is okay
and the screen is showing
which it looks like everything is good
to go alrighty so just bear with me here
[Music]
and we'll get started okay great i see a
bunch of yeses there and it's good good
again yeah i'm glad uh you guys are able
to take some time out from these crazy
markets it's uh
you know this all this inflation stuff
that's going on it's kind of depressing
actually you know and
you go to the store you're spending more
on food you're going to the gas station
obviously we're spending a heck of a lot
more on gas and
you know
unfortunately
you look at your paycheck a lot of times
it's not growing it's not growing as
much as you'd like it to grow and so
sometimes you got to supplement that
income
through you know
other means and you know for a lot of
people it's trading and what i want to
talk about today is
the new indicator that we have from
order flows which is called the flow
smasher
and
you know it it's a great tool that in my
opinion can help you know
it's going to help many traders and you
know a lot of traders
struggle with order flow right they
struggle trying to make sense of all the
numbers that are coming through because
you know it is intimidating and you know
we create these tools to help traders uh
you know shorten that learning curve so
to speak now before we begin again you
know we're all adults in the room we do
understand the risks involved in trading
now
when you really think about it there's
trading you know people trade
on an institutional level
for
two reasons right to increase
their risk
in order to make more money right
they're going to put on bigger positions
their risk is going to increase because
they want to ultimately make more money
in the market or two they want to
reduce the risk of losing money in the
market and when a trader wants to
increase or
reduce their risk they have to step up
to the plate and trade and when big
traders trade volume naturally is going
to increase and
when the market starts trading through
you know above average solid volume it's
a sign of a healthy market right i mean
that's you know sort of goes back to
you know the
uh
you know i'll say the early days the
technical analysis but you know
volume
i think it was granville who said you
know volume is the uh you know fuel to
make the engine go
further and further the engine being the
markets now
the way i like to think of it is you
know it's a bit like pac-man right you
you have to sort of
work your way through volume right to
get to you know the prize ultimately you
know it's going to be and pac-man is the
cherry you know it's the fruits and
you're going to be running into those
goblins you know people you know the fed
or um you know news announcements etc
but ultimately to get
to where you want to go market has to
eat through size and it's hard for a lot
of traders to understand the size that's
going through in the market and when
you're looking at a footprint chart a
lot of times people don't realize that
you know the volume that's just
occurring
preceding where you're trading right now
will affect
how the market is going to trade
in the near term right the volume that's
happening you know over these bars right
in here you know
at uh this is a 6 40 this morning right
you got one two three you know the
volume that's appearing here
affects how this market can potentially
come out and move
right this is ultra bonds this is just
you know a couple hours ago
the volume that's happening right in
here
right before the signal kicks off is
is um needs to be analyzed right is that
volume picking up in the sense of you
know are the
one do you have you know sort of people
putting in bigger orders but two
obviously do you have people trading
those orders it's one thing to have big
orders hit the market you need to have
um
you know people eat through that and
that's a big thing people that look at
you know resting liquidity okay nothing
wrong with looking at resting liquidity
a lot of the issue that i see with a lot
of traders is they don't understand that
when the market is eating through solid
volume
right
it's a market with a head of steam it's
going to keep going it's going to often
keep moving now
it's easy if you're looking at a book
map to see where these areas are and
honestly when you're looking at things
like a heat map
you know market depth you see big size
people like to fade it right they like
to jump in front
and now with the advent of you know
execution algos and orders getting split
up chopped up every which way
people are hiding their intentions
they're hiding their size so you know
sometimes you do see it on the market
depth oftentimes you don't see it but
where you do see it is when it trades in
the market
and to be honest the volume that's
trading in here looks pretty average
right but unless you understand the
volume that's going through the relative
volume
meaning relative to
what's just been trading
right if it's increasing and sometimes
it's very discreet right you don't
really notice it and that's why these
banks and trading firms pay
millions of dollars to their i.t
department to develop these algos to
really massage their orders in without
affecting the market
but when this volumes you know i call it
a little bit of a spike and spike is not
the best phrase to use because when you
think of spike you think a big jump but
really what you're seeing is sort of you
know more volume getting sort of
massaged into the market and you know
that's a sign
of a market that's often ready to
make a move
okay now
what the flow smasher does it's going to
analyze the volumes
obviously in the bar that we're in and
we're going to start comparing it to
volumes in the bars
just preceding it right now it doesn't
necessarily mean that just because you
have a big volume bar that automatically
you know it's a trade no you know here
this is 894. over here's a thousand but
you start analyzing how the volumes are
going through um you know relative
to that volume spike and it's not just
the total volume right you gotta it
breaks it down um by volume traded on
the bid volume trading on the offer
within certain areas within the bars you
know there's certain boundaries that
you're going to be looking for
in the order flowing you don't have to
the flow smasher will do that for you
so let's just take a look at the
settings really quick i'm going to take
you through some actual charts in a
minute but i just want to take you
through some of these settings now
you know some of the the people that
have got the version already
have been saying that
i'm going to be uploading a newer
version right for some reason
the version that
a couple users have doesn't have the
region one region too but
by this afternoon it's going to be all
sorted out it's
yeah sometimes you just got to refresh
the link i think
you know it had the old version but if
you just refresh the link
it should give you that new version but
there's basically what
flow smasher does is it breaks down
order flow in a bar by regions okay
there's region one region two and
there's another area called flow
expansion okay we also have a swing
filter so if you're looking for sort of
swing highs or swing lows you can
determine the length of
the swing high or you know swing low
okay
but really what i'll focus on are you
know the different regions now
originally when i watched the order flow
it was
region one right that was the certain
area in the bar
um
that would be analyzed let me get my
pointer here you know it'd be analyzed
you know certain areas within the bar
where the volume is and then it's going
to start comparing it you know how's the
total volume of the bar relative to
previous bars and how is that order flow
in that region
of the bars being compared to previous
regions as well
and
as you know serendipity would have it it
became you know i was just looking at it
from one angle but then once we were
able to
put it down into an indicator we
won
well i was doing it anyway one is the
flow expansion which is this other
setting down here
which would expand the area expands the
region a little bit right because you
know on more volatile markets
it's gonna you know
volume is going to be spread out in the
bar right i mean you can't look at say
you know a nasdaq bar and treat it the
same you would an ultrabond bar right
you have to expand
the area of analysis just because you
know the price discovery is taking a lot
longer a lot further
than you know on a tighter market like
you know ultra bonds or 10 years or
regular bonds
but the region 2
right is just
it's similar to region one it's just
another area in the bar that once we're
able to start breaking it down um you
know with the computer and look at
different areas you know we found this
to be a highly useful
area as well and you know honestly
one of the the testers is like you know
what you could actually
run it separately as a separate
indicator in the sense of you know have
region one running um you know on one
chart have region two on another chart
of course you could put them both on the
same
um the same chart as well you could even
you know what some people have been
telling me they were doing was
they would use and again i'll show you
when i get to
the different charts you know on the
regions
splitting it up on a chart you could
actually put two instances of flow
smasher so you just uh you know add it
again and you'd have one showing just
region one another one with region two
and you just change the colors okay
but
when i when i get to the actual charts
it'll all make sense
now
best markets to trade again i'm a
futures trader you know my focus has
always been on futures markets
ever since i got started right i started
on the cme floor and i'm from chicago if
i was in new york who knows might be
equities but
everything that i design and we get
programmed is
mainly for futures markets and the
reason for that is you know the data
comes from one source comes from the
exchange when you start looking at
things like forex and even um you know
stocks you get all these different
data sources so to speak um
but
futures markets definitely um uh stocks
yeah i prefer if you're going to look at
stocks i suggest you look at the main
um you know the dow 30 stocks for sure
and you know some of the bigger nasdaq
stocks i don't recommend you know get
involved in these um penny stocks i also
love commodities commodities is great
for trading order flows you don't get
the crazy swings you do like like you
get in equities like just you know the
last couple of days bonds are also good
markets to trade um you know right now
some of the metals you know gold copper
um are
are great to follow
crude oil again it's a bit volatile um
you know you're getting
you know
two three dollar moves
um you know pretty quick in there and
it's just the price discovery is
happening super fast it's sort of
trading like nasdaq now chart types
time based tick based volume based okay
those are the ones that i prefer renko
you know i know some people that uh love
renko's i've never really been a big fan
of and generally order flow
the way wrinkle charts are constructed
order flow doesn't really fit in well um
i do know some people that use hiking
ashy with order flow as well but you
know i i'm a
old-school person i stick with
time-based
uh charred stick based volume based now
one thing to keep in mind right if
you're using tick based charts or volume
based charts when you're trading
overnight
like asian session european session
you're going to
run into those areas where
you just have the light volumes
okay
and it's just going to take time for
everything
to
sort of
form right i mean you you look at a tick
based chart during the us hours and you
know sometimes some
depending on your duration of the tick
base you know 50 bit you know say it's
ultra bonds a 50 tick chart
um
you know it could trade almost as a one
minute chart whereas overnight is
trading like a 10 minute chart 15 minute
chart so just bear that in mind
and
you know before i get into some of these
markets
and the settings you know volatile
markets okay
you know
i i i get emails from traders oh you
know it's been tough lately in the
markets well if the markets are too
volatile just stay away honestly
extremely volatile markets
are going to cause traders
to struggle i mean right now
what's the vix at vixx is like at 32
right it's quite high
um
it's strange because it's
vixen above 25 lately has just been it's
been being normalized and if you're in a
market like m and q
it's you know
volumes are just going to be spread out
and it's going to be hard to do any sort
of
in my opinion useful order flow analysis
but that's why we added the flow
expansion
is to sort of widen out the area that
the order flow will look at
and you could also add a swing filter
you know you'd start with one you know
as your base and sort of work your way
up now i say start at one i don't mean
try one two three four you go one and
you maybe shoot it up to like five or
three and then five and then you know
ten
um you want sort of mains
what's the word legitimate swings um you
know one being the smallest right
meaning that it would have to be higher
than the previous bar or lower than the
previous bars
now okay so settings
generally when i talk about settings i
break it down into
four types i got what i call short term
which is like 30 seconds to one minute
and to be honest if you're looking at a
30 second chart that would be on
markets that are a bit more volatile
again it's it's one of those things you
know some people get scared thinking oh
i gotta look at a 30 second chart no you
don't have to you know if you're using a
one minute chart you're comfortable stay
with it but me
you know when market volatility picks up
i tend to go a little bit uh
shorter time frame rather than longer
time frame because i go longer time
frame
than on a volatile market
you're putting more at risk right
because
as volatility picks up and you know your
normal
say 10 point stop in nasdaq also now
you're using a 20-25 point stopping
minute i'd rather just
shrink it down a little bit and
try and you know keep a realistic stop
intact uh longer term i talk about
longer term i mean five minutes or more
um
tick based
you know i
i generally stick with you know certain
levels you know 50 100 200
you know maybe in es
uh yeah you could probably go 500
and volume based
again depending on the market you know
if it's
a
smaller market you know you could use
250 as the volume even though i got 500
written there but like for e-minis you
know a thousand two thousand again it's
up to you whether you want to use a 90
you know you want to use a fib number
987 ticks or you know 987 volume you
know whatever 1587 so yeah you can
adjust it right it's not set in stone
but generally that's my guidelines so
i'll start with uh
buns okay let me get the chart up here
so for buns
um where's my chart whoops not that
chart uh where are you here
okay blends here so
let's just take a look at the settings
here so
open it up
and
okay so this is
region two right now so region one
actually i have a region one on here
uh i guess not um we'll go back to
region one then region one is where i
always start out at okay um region one
is is how i originally programmed
the indicator based on how i would look
at the order flow okay
region one i'm not using flow expansion
again this is just you know your vanilla
one minute chart
okay
and
again you can see
these signals here let me get the
crosshairs up okay so this is
region one right seeing some cells in
here again it doesn't
these moves don't look like much but
this is actually a decent move from 62
you know 30
30 tick move here but you know it's
catching some nice moves up now region
two
or before i get to region two let me
explain flow expansion okay now honestly
on a market like buns i probably
wouldn't use flow expansion
simply because
the market trades pretty normal it's not
you know you're not getting
wide price bars in the sense of um
you know it's moving 10 20 ticks within
a minute it's generally
pretty
a pretty stable market but if i were to
add flow expansion
you're going to see
more
more signals right you can see here
there's decidedly more it's because it's
expanding the area of analysis
all right that's what flow expansion
does
now on bonds like i said i probably
wouldn't recommend it for most traders
um just because buns is a pretty stable
market obviously you know there's a lot
of talk you know what's ecb going to do
um you know fed was you know did 75
um
you know i think there was an emergency
meeting with
in europe with the central bank
but um generally it's a pretty normal
market okay now
you can see the signals here for region
one if i were to go to region
right it's going to be a different set
of signals
because it's looking at different things
different areas in the order flow and
doing different whoops doing different
comparisons
right that's what it's it's comparing
not just what's happening in this bar
but it's comparing the order the current
order flow with previous bars
okay so again you can still see right
it's sort of keeping you still on the
right side of the market now
if you want to compare them together
just really quick here we'll do it this
way
um
again i have no swing filter turned on
here what i'll do is i'll just change
the colors so the region 2 is your
blue and red and for region one
you know we'll make it uh cyan just you
know just for visual purposes here
cyan and
magenta
okay
so
you
sh you won't get since they look at
different areas region one region two
the areas of
analysis
is different right that the signals are
going to be different so you could see
this light blue is
the region one the dark blue is region
two
okay
so for example right the region two
sorry the region one caught that
sell-off um that happened after you know
basically after 12 from you know 140 350
down to 143 even
region
two didn't did not
okay so there's those those slight
differences
uh by looking at region one region two
well some people will put them both up
there
okay and just look at all of them right
they want to see all the signals that
come through now
if
if i add flow expansion on both of these
you're going to see
a lot more signals
let's just give it a second here um you
know then i'll sort of get into so you
can see there's a lot more signals and
again depending on the type of trader
you are some people love a lot of
signals right because they're just
really looking to sort of scalp just a
few ticks here and there this is one way
that you can do it right if you really
want to you know if you're very active
trader and you're just looking to scalp
tick here and there
now
if you really want to start filtering
out trades you know looking for swing
highs or swing lows then you just click
on the swing filter right the default is
five
and
you know if you so it would have to be
a swing high by at least you know five
bars
let me uh
set that up
and you know a lot of those signals are
going to disappear
right because now it's looking for a
swing high or swing low in addition
to the order flow
okay so
again you're just seeing you know just a
few signals here now
right not much
again i would really only use the swing
filter in more volatile markets you know
markets that
take longer for price discovery you know
for
price to transact at
solid volumes right when and buns again
is one of those markets that is is
fairly normal right you don't
necessarily have to
um
you know worry about a lot of
turkey jerky movements you know
somebody sneezed and the market rallied
uh three points or anything like that so
um
that is that is buns again for buns you
know region one
you compare region one region two but
flow expansion i would not use flow
expansion in there now let's take a look
at um
ultra bonds okay ultra bonds is a great
market right i'll get to equities in a
minute but
you know i'd rather talk about some of
these other markets that
are often
overlooked by
by traders basically um you know they
think that
a lot of traders come to the market
everyone's always talking about e-minis
uh about nasdaq but there's really a
whole
plethora you if you will of markets out
there
that are very tradable
right
and i don't have time to go into it but
you know if you've ever looked at the
order flow in commodities
right
it follows commodities or order
commodities follow the order flow very
nicely the reason for that in my opinion
is because
the participants are are different right
you don't have that big retail
participation that's
you know sort of like this herd
mentality
the only hard mentality you have are you
know the big
users of the products you know people
that are buying the corn people are
buying the wheat that have to use it
right and
that's why you see great trends
oftentimes in commodities that trends
that run for really long periods is
because
you have that collective of
end users that that need to buy the
commodity right they need it because
they need to manufacture stuff you know
in
things like you know
s ps
russell
you know people aren't buying it to
use it they're behind it to speculate so
you don't have that that necessarily
that speculation so this is a 50 tick
chart in
ultra bonds okay
so start with
region one okay so
here's my notes right
start with region one compared to region
two then watch when i'm going to add in
um
which we'll call it uh
full expansion okay so just to make it
easy rather than keep flipping through
the charts what i'm gonna do is i'm
going to add the
region 1 region 2 for region 2 i'm just
going to make it a different color just
to sort of differentiate it
cyan and magenta
just so you get the idea of you know
should i be using region one or region
two now there's some markets right and
this was the
great now i'll say discovery but you
know the great thing of being able to do
this analysis a lot easier with computer
is
it
there's some markets where region two
just really dominates you know i sent
you guys a bunch of charts yesterday um
with just region two like in the e-minis
ultra bonds
and um
euro currency right with just region two
enabled so you can see here right the
blue and red
is the normal region one this magenta
the cyan
this cyan by this magenta cell
um region two
right this is another magenta cell
okay
now
again you know if
you were to say you were to add
flow expansion i wouldn't add flow
expansion on on a tight market like um
actually it is on here already
but let's take it off there
i would not add flow expansion on the
ultra bond on a 50 tick chart if
again flow expansion is really meant for
you know markets are a bit more volatile
so here we go
okay so
again there's your signals
okay now again if you add flow expansion
you will see more trades
and
then obviously the next step is you know
sometimes people get oh my gosh there's
so many trades you know i don't want
these all these trades you know they
just want to take you know sort of the
market turning points um you know that's
when you'd use a swing filter
um
you know what was it you know five i say
you could start at one let's take a look
at at one okay for both of these
okay so you can see
this one probably go away you know a
bunch of these will go away i'll see
what we're left with here
okay so you know this is a swing filter
of one it's a lot cleaner right and
you're getting some nice trades
obviously you got that nice move down a
little pop here a little move there a
little move there
right if you were to expand it out to
say five
you know again
when you expand your swing filter out
more
you're going to start seeing lesser
and lesser trades right so you don't
have your cell signal over here but
you're still getting you know these sort
of these major turning points in the
markets
okay so
close that down now let's go on to uh a
little bit longer time frame um
let's talk about
five-minute charts okay so mes
your currency i would use the same right
on longer term charts i would start with
both areas of the order flow region one
region two and um the flow expansion so
sort of getting in here i think this is
my
five minute chart okay
now
i should get two here so this one the
first one is
this is just region one with flow
expansion
okay so you see a couple signals
you know caught that nice trend since
last night since basically overnight to
you know once it broke right here that
big bar down
and then obviously continued on down
this is region one
um
this one is region two
and region one okay take off region
one
there
euro currency
this is a five minute chart while i'm
waiting for the euro the mes to come
back up um this is region one and region
two right with flow expansion
so
you know when i'm looking at
longer term i like to put them all up
there and again you can differentiate
which is region one region two by simply
going into the setting
and
you know changing you know you just
basically what you want to do
if you want to look at both of them sort
of separately
is you just add two instances of it
right so you got one two you just make
one
um region one and the other one region
two just change the color
so that you know because you're going to
find sometimes that you know some
markets
depending on on the chart type but
there's just so many different chart
types out there that people look at um
you know trying to
cover them all
is too much because you know something i
get these i get messages from people
and they're like oh you know i use this
type of chart type
how does the indicator work on that and
really it's i've
i can't give an answer because i've
never looked at that type of chart i got
to pull it up
um
you know just because there's i do
realize you know everybody has their own
different view of the markets or the the
longer term views of the market or
shorter term views you know again i know
people that use three tick i'll show you
three range bars sometimes
um and it's just i'm like i i got
how's that working for you you know but
they're able to make it work i mean
personally i would if i have a nervous
breakdown if i was looking at a three
range chart especially with the way the
market moves so you can see here right
the cyan the sort of the different
colors coming in
so my mes chart hasn't come back up yet
but i just give it a second so i still
forming now
i'm going to get to questions in a
second but um
a question that people ask you know um
markers right the automated
uh system system right the the tool from
the indicator store you know pablo
that allows traders to
um
automate an indicator yes it does work
with markers these are the instructions
and you know i'm going to add this into
the user guide i i didn't have it in the
user guide earlier but it's really
simple to set up in markers and
again you know if you've ever used
markers
in a little bit comfortable with you
with it it'll literally take you about
a minute or two
to set it up in markers um you know to
run and
let's see here
okay so back to this mes i want to take
it through markers in a second here
but you can see here right so this is
region two
this chart is region one
right so obviously on region two you did
have that
um
that sell-off
but then you had to buy signal the
market keeps on off you got your cell
signal here which again sort of
corresponds with some cell signals start
coming in around that same area-ish it's
a little bit lower
on you know a bar too lower after the
the two cell signals there um
you know gold
okay it's 100 tick chart in the gold
gold was a nice mover today
right you can see yeah you know okay you
had a small trade here maybe a small
loss here a loss here you know you get a
trade here small loss then you catch
that big runner right here i mean look
how this thing just kept running
right you get a small little trade here
but again you know
18 30
in here
all right this is 37 actually 37 30
right in here
all the way up into the 50s
and and higher
and this one is
i think this one's region
two two with the swing filter on and
flow expansion
um look at
another chart so this is e
uh euro
currency what do i got on here again
this one
not the prettiest chart this is just
plain region one um that's explaining
the emails yesterday you know region two
is something you want to look at but
look at this okay so people say well you
got stopped out here well this is this
doesn't look like much of a move but
it's actually
oh what does that move
i mean your currency's moving nicely you
know you're talking to move from about
you know it's not a 15 point move here
um you know just lately you know the
market's been
rocking and rolling right so yeah you
get stopped out
here
you get stopped out here then you catch
the big runner from you know
104.60
all the way up
you know even if you cut it here
105 17 you know a 60. 60 tick move in
the euro currency
right this is
this is the euro currency with region
two that was region one this is region
two
okay so again charts a bit different
all right you're getting a bit
more frequent signals
right that's why we've added both region
one and region two because some people i
realize may prefer
using both of them
okay
now
let me
do something here really quick i'm going
to switch off onto
i'm going to go through the setup really
quick for markers
so i'm going to
disconnect there
again i don't have a lot of data
loaded up in here
on my chart
oh i was going to take you through the
ultra bonds really quick but while
that's loading
um you know just just a couple questions
i saw you know what what is it based on
the order flow okay
so again
what it's looking at right if i could
make this
bigger laser pointer here yeah
is yeah you're seeing the signal coming
on this bar
right the conditions are being met
because what is being analyzed in the
order flow throughout this bar
right is being compared
to the previous bars
so it's not just taking you know well
how's the trading happening in this bar
is it strong well it is it's right it's
taking what's happening now and realizes
it's strong but not only that how does
it compare to
the recent activity
right is it strong or not or is it just
sort of your normal order flow that's
going through
right just like here in the
ultra bonds today right
you're seeing this sort of shape up in
here right that the volume is picking up
in here
but it's one thing to have volume just
start to pick up
how does that compare to
the volume
that was just trading
immediately before it
right it's not just the total volumes of
the bar people say well i figured it out
you see the volume spiked up to 503
that's it no it's not it's watching how
it's being traded in the bar relative to
how it was being traded
in the previous bars in the previous
bars
and you know it's sort of it's finding
out those
areas where
you're starting to see that increase
right and
many of us
aren't privy to you know sort of how
these execution out goes work right like
t web b web but you know i've been
fortunate enough that i've been exposed
to that at working at
jp morgan at that time when you know all
these execution algos were starting to
um
really take hold in the marketplace in
the past the execution algo was a guy
sitting at the desk executing it
manually with a little timer you know a
little egg timer sort of speaking of
those digital timers
watching the market whereas now it's all
being programmed into computers
and you know when people
when these firms
create these algos these execution algos
they're looking at v web how does
how does it know right they even got you
know these t-waf it's looking at volume
relative to previous volumes right and
some of these things are quite
sophisticated i know that for example
right people have orders they say i'll
execute my order starting at at 9 00 a.m
and run it until 9 30 okay
now in the old days what a broker would
do was
they would execute the order starting at
nine okay the orders for what 100
contracts they just split it up over the
half hour period now all they do is just
enter the details in okay you know
by 500 e-minis starting at nine until
9 30
and
beat v-web right so it's not going to
just take what's happening right now it
also looks at how the volumes were over
time over the last 10 days the last 50
days etc to compare it so it has a
benchmark of knowing should it be
speeding up or not you know because you
know they just you know these these guys
just love massaging
data in that sense but it doesn't have
to be that complex all right everyone
likes to make it complex
but really what you're looking for is
that jump in volume right and oftentimes
it's pretty subtle
it doesn't stick out like a sore thumb
it's just it's a gradual buildup right
because what's happening is now they
have the you know the big traders using
their execution now goes
executing more and more right as this
market starts
inching away
right from the from its sort of its
balance area
all right so uh okay so here i am
hopefully i'm all set up
um
getting set up on this
market replay here all right so where is
my
chart this one here all right so i've
already got it set up here but
um
let's take you through the setup really
quick you know what you're going to do
when you set it up on markers again this
is you don't get markers obviously this
is meant for people that
already have markers okay just you know
show you how
show you the setup on how simple it is
all you really got to do is
i like to use um
markers
copy
okay and so there's markers of force and
there's markers copy all you got to do
right is you just go in there you add
markers copy
twice one for the buys one for the cells
then you're going to add markers the
force and
again when you go inside you do have to
make a couple adjustments right i do
also add the actual indicator
you know the flow smasher on there but
once you're inside
okay you have to make some adjustments i
use um
best signals mode right so enable longs
enable shorts change the fast signal
name from long and short
and
again depending on your account size you
can adjust the max daily profit max
daily loss
and then also add in markers copy again
one for the buys
one for the cells
and you just change the variable name
the longs right because you already told
it to look for
longs you gotta enable fast signal mode
then on each tick
and i always change the
plot to the same
you know so for buys it's
blue triangle up
right size of eight but then in here
right the input series
you have to
go in and set up the flow smasher okay
so you know you just click on that
uh wait for the box next oh here it is
so my
ninjatrader is acting up um you just add
flow smasher right then you just change
it to whatever settings you want to use
it for
region one
i'm just going to have it for region one
on this example you change this plot to
buy signal okay
and you do the same thing
for the cell right you'd go into the
other instance
of markers copy and change it to cell
same thing you like but you change this
variable
to short so whatever you named it
under markers plus the force
obviously you got to
go back to the input series make sure
you enable it to the right settings that
you're looking for and you got to make
sure you tell it to
look for the shorts okay because you've
got to have one for buys one for cells
again you know once you're familiar with
the program
um
it's very easy to use right so you just
set it to whatever setting right region
one and i just make sure i change this
here from buy signal to sell signal okay
simple
and again i would just you know change
it to calculate on each tick and
you're going to copy
all right make sure the plots are the
same and that's it
okay and then you know when you're going
to use it you just make sure you got it
turned on
um you know make sure you have your
right atm strategy showing up in here um
you know your account matches up those
are just sort of those like last minute
checks that you'd go through before you
start running
anything
you should continue
no
when i press i press something there
just
and that's it basically right you just
that's how you would set it up right i
just have it set up here in playback i'm
just using a vanilla um atm strategy
that i have of 8x10
and just uh
sort of take you through it
like you know at night like i was saying
earlier right at night it's uh
you can't use flow smasher at overnight
sessions right a lot of the markets have
very tradable order flow overnight um
i watch the overnights
you know like i got kids so i stay up
late my kids for some reason love
staying up until uh last night they're
up until two in the morning
um
so
i tend to find myself so there right it
got into the trade now again you know
for me when i use
markers i like to manage the trade
rather than just you know leaving a take
profit
take
or you know my take profit or my stop
just at the sort of
arbitrary level i'll say arbitrary
levels but you know fixed dollar amounts
i i like to watch the order flow
and it's if it's conducive
you know if market's trending in my way
move the order right move my take profit
to uh
to a more advantageous spot or if i
start seeing order flow come in again
i'm showing you this on a bar chart
you could use it on a footprint chart
um you know as well you're not
limited now you do need to use
tick replay
okay you have to have it enabled uh tick
replay on on your system
it's very simple to do
you know i've got tutorials out there
about it and all that so
again um you know that's how easy it is
to set up on markers so i'm going to
take uh some questions here
does it okay there's a question here for
an orphan is this an indicator good
starting point yeah you know
i actually recommend some of my
indicators as a starting point just to
you know sort of give people
a leg up on getting used to order flow
because oftentimes you know when you're
watching order flow a lot of traders
don't know what to look for
so it's just one of those things that
you know is going to help you
in the long run by giving you a little
bit as you get better with order flow
maybe you start moving away from an
indicator or you just keep it on there
and but now you're looking at certain
things because honestly
it's one of those that uh you know you
just want to
really get up to speed as as quickly
um
key asks i sent you an order
i'll take a look key i didn't see your
email
let me make a note here
i'll take a look
it might be in my spam folder
um
where would one execute on the buy or
sell signal okay well
you know you have a
buy or sell signal
now we have what we call the trade entry
signal so as soon if you're using the
trade entry signal
let me just stop this here so
like like you're using the trade entry
signal okay
you'll notice right there's some zones
being drawn out here right it's telling
you the order flow is met but you don't
see
a
red triangle for a cell or a blue
triangle for a buy you see one here you
see a couple here that's telling you
that's the time to get into the trade
because when you're using the trade
entry signal what it does is
it
basically confirms it has a confirmation
process basically the market is moving
in your direction so not only do you
have the order flow
um
it
also has follow-through order flow
right so instead of you know getting
long in here right it's keeping you up
because you don't have that follow
through order flow you know the market
ticked up um you know 0.506
it didn't do it in a quick enough
fashion
right that's just that's another
feature that we have
already programmed in there if you want
to use it it's called it's right here if
you disable the straight entry signal
then
you'll get a sell signal here a buy
signal here a cell signal there
you know you'll get a sell signal here
you get a buy signal here right
do you
want to take this by no there was no
follow-through order flow even though
the conditions were sort of being met
here
you still need to follow through order
flow it's just not there it's just not
happening right in here
you are getting that follow-through
order flow
um
flow breaks
okay all my indicators are different
okay they're all based on different
aspects of the order flow and you know
this question i get
often is you know how is this the same
you know sometimes the names look the
same but no they're different
order flow is
so robust and again you know that's
um you know i i want to talk about it
here really quick
i sort of got away from my slides
but
when you get
the flow smasher right next week i'm
doing a
order flow nuances workshop right i want
to talk about all these little different
nuances because you know
what traders do is you know they find a
part of order flow
that
resonates with them right that just sits
well that they just understand they know
exactly what to look for in the order
flow right and they just focus on that
and i take it through a bunch of those
instances
and
again this is
when you get the postmaster only give
you access to the it's
the pages um
it's ready it's going to be a live
session on thursday and friday next week
and there will be recordings
but you know if you want to
you'll get access to it
with the flow smasher so you could one
you could either you know join in on the
live sessions or if you can't attend the
live sessions um you'll have access to
the replays this is just you know this
is a bonus i want to throw in to
the flow smasher because you know i do
want traders to understand you know
different ways to look at the markets
through order flow rather than just sort
of focusing on one thing because you
know at the end of the day what's
happening in the markets there's so many
different little
levers
you know being pulled push pulled
that
there's instances where looking at this
might be better for you as opposed to
looking at this right different way to
look at point of control as opposed to
um you know or comparing you know where
point of control is appearing in a bar
you know where imbalances are appearing
in the bar how these these different
little nuances appear and
again you know you're going to get
access to this order flow
nuances workshop that i'm putting on
next week and you're not going to be
charged for it right we
access you know people that
want access to it that haven't bought
flow smasher are going to
have to pay for it right they're going
to
you know this is the page here
you know we're still working on it
and you know sort of getting into sort
of the details of it
of what's going to be covered
i think's key i'll take a look right
after this
um
does it okay because richard had asked
you know does the arrow plot when the
bar opens or when it closes it looks
like
our counting from when it opens no it
okay if you're using the trade entry
signal
it will appear
once the bar closes right and once the
bar closes that's it right the signal is
printed it won't change if you are using
if you're not using the trade entry
signal when as soon as the conditions
are met you're going to see the triangle
but if the bar is still open right if
it's say you're using a one minute bar
and it's only 35 seconds into the bar
you've still got 25 seconds left
it can repaint or disappear rather
because the conditions change
but once the bar closes
if it's there it will always remain
there it won't it won't change
another question yeah john you can use
it as a standalone indicator right you
see me i have it on a normal bar chart
here right i don't have the footprint
chart running will you if you're going
to use it
obviously any of my order flow tools
especially this one is
uh tick replay
tick replay you know ninja trader 8 when
they released it a couple years ago more
than a couple years ago and the big
difference was how how it handled
historical data and by enabling tick
replay
it allows you to analyze past order flow
so yeah you have to have tick replay
enabled but yeah you can use it as a
standalone indicator on ninjatrader
right i've all these charts are
standalone charts i have it on a
footprint i have it on a normal bar
chart right just showing you know where
they appear
um
a question those candles with the
numbers inside them you don't need that
no you don't need to use a
footprint chart
right the question was
do i need to use
where's my footprint here do i need to
use a footprint chart like this
to use it no you don't you
run it on
a normal bar chart
right your normal bar chart
okay your normal bar chart
so
yeah you could use it on a normal bar
chart
ed
yeah ed i
saw your email
we're going to take care of that so mina
asks what region 1 and region 2 refer to
what it refers to region 1 region 2 is
where
so for example right where in the bar
that it's analyzing the order flow to
compare it to the previous bars
so
originally region one was
when i would
trade order flow without
you know just basically the naked
footprint chart like this you know
looking for
actionable order flow that was just
region one we opened up to region two
once we started
doing additional um
analysis of the order flow
uh let's see here
and how about volume or delta charts
well again i just showed you the
it would be the same uh actually i don't
have delta volume charts
you know volume charts again it would be
the same you'd you'd
be looking at the same i've cut this on
uh
complete historically let me just uh go
back to
uh
hang on a sec here so let's just take a
look here
all right uh
so for example well gold okay tick chart
okay let's see if i can change it to a
volume chart i don't know what you want
to change it to
if i change it to a volume chart you
know the same thing
i would start with the same settings
and go from there
ryan i
brian
i didn't see your emails brian i
apologize
that's why i haven't gotten back
uh let's see here
let's see
um
john well
the workshop is is really meant for
people on a footprint chart because it's
going to be hard to see things
um
you know on a
on a regular bar chart right so you can
see here okay there's some trades this
is a 200 volume chart but again it's the
same you know you'd
the same setting that i had on on the
what was it a 100
100 tick chart i think it was you know
this was region two with the swing
filter and flow expansion
um
ted asks
what is the best
ortho indicators
well
if you're just looking at indicators
itself
um
you know because there are there are a
few that i got out there and
it really depends on the type of trader
you are for one you know are you more of
a shorter term trader like a scalper or
a bit of a longer term if you're a
shorter term you know all the like the
the flows
indicators that i have you know like the
flow smasher
full scalper those are good for shorter
term
traders more of a swing term you know
honestly swing traders but a little bit
more longer term
yeah i'd look at some of the other tools
like turns
pulse
delta scalper as well so again it's i've
been working on a sort of like a
spreadsheet that compares and
talks about the different indicators um
so you could get a better idea of you
know
what type of indicator would suit you
um
you know just really quick like someone
had asked what's the difference between
say pulse and uh flow smasher well pulse
what the overflow's pulse looks for is
momentum
picking up because momentum
can just shift really faster what the
flow smasher does
it looks a different
aspect of the order flow
but it's taking it relative to a certain
period that
say the pulse obviously doesn't take
that into account at all and it's just
really looking for order flow within the
bar not relative to
um
you know a certain period
prior to that uh to that bar
well all right guys again i don't keep
guys on all afternoon um you know i've
been on for about an hour so again you
know if you want to get the flow smasher
right now we got that
introductory price
and if you want access to the uh
workshop for free you know just go ahead
and get started
so
yeah arby i'll get that out uh
when uh
when we get it all together
so again you know if you've got any
questions just shoot me an email key
i'll take a look at the emails um brian
i'd i'll search again for your emails
maybe i missed it but um you know
hopefully you guys found this useful and
you know it again you know
these markets are crazy now
and it takes more than one way to look
at the market sometimes and that's why
we have these tools because we do
realize we do know that market
conditions are constantly changing you
know sometimes people say well you know
i have a mean reversion system well
okay a day like today it's been selling
off since midnight last night your mean
reversion
how's that working for you we're in a
strong trend day down so have a great
rest of your day everybody and i'll talk
to you guys later bye
you